OBVIOUSLY, ON THE OTHER TEAM. -
>> Sam: THAT BRINGS A COUPLE TI
PENOTHER YOUNG
PLAYER ON DEFENSE.
THAT'S A STRAIGHT SCORES!
ALLOWS THE FLYERS KRIEDERCKBOAR
ZIBANEJAD, IT'S ON HIM.
BACK.
THE SHOT WENT WIDE.
CHTHER A-ONE
FLYERS GETTING A COUPLE GOOD
CHANCES HERE. LOOKING.
PANARIN SH
TAP-IN GOAL.
WHAT A FLYERS,
AND SO MANY HIGH QUALITY.
HERE THEY COME AGAIN IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ICE WIDE OPEN AND
IT TURNS OUTA
WRISTS IT AND HE SCORES! IN.
YEAH, THIS IS THE NEW LINE SAM
WAS FLYERS,
VODKA CAM. TWO-ON-ONE,
AND RYAN LINDGREN.
AND HIS RIGHT.
NO, SOMEBODY IS COMING, AND THEN
THE PASS, ANDNDAR IT OUT.
MILLER GETS TO IT. GONE BY IN T.
DRIVING TO THE NET, AND AND ACR
YORK.
BACK TO HAYES.
THEIR FIRST SHOOTOUT WIN